[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه تحقق في اسباب
سقوط مروحيه وزير الداخليه والمانيا تعرض
المشاركه
طويلا
انت سيد الوزن الفائده اوروبا تتجه لادراج
الحرس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب وتدعم
اليه تحقيق في انتهاكات النظام
تراسهم امراه في كابول لبحث تعزيز حقوق
النساء في افغانستان مع طالبه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه قتل وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني ونائبه الاول وعدد من
المسؤولين في حادث سقوط مروحيه قرب روضه
اطفال بالقرب من العاصمه وذكر حاكم كيف ان
مالا يقل عن 18 شخصا لقوا مصراعهم في
الحادث كما تم نقله 22 مصابا الى
المستشفيات مؤكدا ان حالتهم حرجه واوضح ان
من بين القتل طفلين على الاقل
[موسيقى]
القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه اوضحت ان
المروحيه المحطمه في بروفاري تابعه لجهاز
الدوله لحالات الطوارئ واضافت ان الحديث
عن اسباب سقوط مروحيه وزير الداخليه
السابق لاواني في وقت شكلت القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه لجنه التحقيق لمعرفه اسباب
سقوط
وزير الداخليه الاوكرانيه المسؤوله عن
الشرطه والامن داخل اوكرانيا
الذي يلقى حتفه منذ بدء الحرب
معي من كتاب المزيد من المتابعه مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه اهلا وسهلا بك
بدايه اخر المستجدات المتعلقه بسقوط
مروحيه وزير الداخليه ومسرعه مع من كان
معه هل جميع الفرضيات او تشير الى فرضيه
يعني الخطا البشري او الحادث العربي ام لا
ثم تفرضيات تؤكد ان العمل مدبر وربما
السابق همم تصميم
تحياتي طالب في الحقيقه يعني اذا سمحت
اليوم ابدا بهذا العاجل وهو ان مجلس
الوزراء الاوكراني اعلن بالانابه او قائم
بالاعمال باعمال وزير الداخليه
رئيس الشرطه الوطنيه الاوكرانيه والذي
الان بدا فعليا يعني يشغل المنصب منذ
اليوم بعد ان تم اعلانه وزيرا للداخليه
حتى يتم تعيين وزير الداخليه
هذا من جانب طبعا تعالى ان المروحيه كان
فيها همم سيرفسكي وهو وزير الداخليه وكذلك
نائبه وزير الدوله بوزاره الداخليه ومعهم
عدد من الاشخاص لم يتم حتى الان كشف عن
هويته تسعه اشخاص في المروحيه لقوا حتفهم
وكذلك طبعا بعض من المدنيين في ذلك في
رياض الاطفال الذي يتضرر طبعا حتى الان
ارتفع عدد ضحايا الى 18 بعد ان كان اخر
اعلان هو 16 رسمي الان تم الاعلان عن
ثمانيه عشر قتيلا بينهم ثلاثه اطفال
وهنالك حوالي 30 جريحنا الان يتلقون
الرعايه الصحيه في المستشفيات الان قبل
قليل ايضا تم الاعلان عن مفقوده هي سيده
واوصلت ابنائها الى همم الرياضه والاطفال
وقبل كما قالت اختها طبعا في افاده ليئه
تلفزيون الاخرى لانها قبل ان تتحرك يبدو
ان حدث هذا الحادث الان هي مفقوده ولا
يعلمون اذا كانت في الداخل ام لا حتى الان
هي تعتبر مفقوده طبعا العوده الى سؤالك
حول الاسباب طبعا سالت بشكل مباشر الكسيكو
ليه قائد الاداره العسكريه فيك وسالته عن
اسباب هذا الحادث اذا كان هنالك اي تكه
هناك او اي انباء حول ذلك الامر طبعا انهم
لا يستطيعون الان تحديد سبب هذا الحادث
قال ايضا ان الخبراء ما زالوا يعملوا كذلك
طبعا الدفاع الجوي الاخراني
لو سمحت عندما تبدي المانيا رغبتها في
المشاركه في التحقيقات في اسباب سقوط هذه
المروحيه الا يرفع ذلك من منسوب التكهنات
والفرضيات من ان الطائره قد تكون اسقطت
عمدا هذا واحد اثنين لماذا هذا التكتم عن
الشخصيات التسعه الاخرى التي لقد حتفها
ايضا في سقوط الطائره وهل هم من كبار
الجنرالات في الجيش الاوكراني
نعم
للاسف الشديد جميع المسؤولين الذين
قابلناهم في موقع الحدث
وسالناهم بشكل مباشر رفضوا التعليق على
هذا الامر هنالك فقط تكه هناك طالب يعني
انا اقرا في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
تحديدا في القنوات
يعني القنوات التليجرام وهي مشهوره وهي
بعض منها مرجعيه لانها تتبع لي بعض الصحف
الكبيره كذلك في الاعلام الاوكراني هنالك
تداول حول انه قد يكون هذا الامر يعني
هنالك حديث عن انه قد يكون مدبرا او قد
يكون طبعا تعلم ان الرجل هو مسؤول عن جهاز
الامن الوطني مسؤول عن الامن الداخلي تعلم
ان هناك مشاركه بفاعليه كبيره جدا لهذا
الامن الوطني
المدسوسيين سواء كان داخل النظام او خارج
النظام سواء كان خاصه في المناطق التي
يسيطر عليها يعمل جهاز الامن الوطني في
كشف المتعاونين ايضا مع الاتحاد الروسي من
الاوكراني مواطنين اتحدث عن مواطنين
اوكرانيين يعني تعاونوا بشكل او باخر مع
الاتحاد الروسي اذن يعني جهاز الامن لديه
همم يعني همم
لن نقول مشاركه ولكن لديه همم سهم كبير في
الدفاع عن الامن الداخلي الوطني الاوكراني
خاصه في المناطق المناطق القتال او
القريبه من مناطق القتال اول مناطق
المسترد ايضا من همم القوات الروسيه
فهنالك هناك عن انه قد يكون هنالك استهداف
للرجل استهداف ليس فقط للرجل هو نائبه
وحتى وزير الدوله فهذا يترك الوزاره بدون
اهم ثلاثه شخصيات في الوزاره
همم
المروحيه كانت تتجه الى مناطق الجبهه الى
مناطق القتال همم سقطت او تم اسقاطها لا
نعرف حتى الساعه المنطقه التي سقطت فوقها
همم المروحيه هل كانت تشهد اي عمليات قصف
حذيفه ام لا يعني هذه المنطقه هذه داخل
العاصمه كيف وما كان في شيء يعني يدعو الى
انه التنبؤ بمثل هكذا حوادث
نعم برافري هي مدينه قائمه بذاتها هي
مدينه صغيره لكن المدينه تعتبر امتداد
لكيف لا يوجد اي فواصل بين كيف وبين مدينه
برافاري الوصول من هنا من المكان الذي اقف
فيه الى الى برافاري الى مكان الحديث
يتطلب 35 دقيقه هي نفس التضاريس ونفس
طبيعه كيف لا يوجد اي فرق هي لا تشهد اي
عمليات عسكريه في الوقت الراهن كان طبعا
من ضمن المناطق التي كان يسيطر الروس على
جزء منها في وقت حصار همم العاصمه كيف في
همم ايام الحرب الاولى ولكن الان المدينه
المدينه تعيش نفس الوضع الذي تعيشه مدينه
تكييف هي طبعا في اتجاه
الجنوب او الجنوب شرق همم الجبهه وهي هذه
الجبهه الان تشهد عمليات قتال همم تعلم
يعني هناك ايضا تكه هناك ان المروحيه كانت
تتجه الى المنطقه جنوب شرق حيث يوجد خير
صور حيث يوجد ميكاليد في تلك المناطق وهذا
ما كنت تتحدث عنه قبل قليل ان وزير
الداخليه
واجهزته يعملون في المناطق المسترده حديثا
كانت قرى او مدن والبحث عن المتعاونين وما
الى ذلك وطبعا الامن الداخلي بشكل عام فمن
الطبيعي ان يزور وزير الداخليه وهذه ليست
الزياره الاولى له لمناطق القتال او
الجبهه او حتى المناطق المسترده طيب
متى من المتوقع ان تكشف السلطات
الاوكرانيه عن باقي من كان مع همم وزير
الداخليه ونائبه وكنت قد سالتك هل يمكن ان
نتوقع ان في جنرالات يعني بيرتب عاليه
كانوا كانوا على متن المروحيه ولقوا حتفهم
ايضا
نعم اذا كان هنالك طبعا جنرالات يعني هذا
ما اتوقعه هذا بطبيعه عمله هنا همم اذا
كان هنالك جنرالات برتب رفيعه في هذه
المروحيه كان ذلك سيكون واضحا يعني
الاعلام الاوكراني لا يترك شيئا دون
التحقق منه او همم لا تكون يعني همم لن
تكون هنالك خبايا مثل هذه الاعلام يتوقع
انه كان سيكون معروفا اسامي الشخصيات هذا
من جانب من جانب اخر طبعا قال وزير همم
قال همم مجلس الوزراء كذلك مكتب الرئيس
كذلك قائد القوات الجويه يومين سوف نكشف
عن جميع همم يعني عن التفاصيل بشكل كامل
ونتيجه
مراسل العربيه حذيفه عادل شكرا جزيلا لك
حذيفه على كل هذه المتابعه
هذا وجدد وزير الخارجيه الروسيه سيرجيله
فروف اتهامه لو واشنطن بالاعداد لحرب
طويله وصفها بالهجينه ضد روسيا عبر ما
يحدث في اوكرانيا لا بربع اعتبر في
تصريحاته ان الاتحاد الاوروبي خاضع بشكل
كامل لما اسماها بالديكتاتوريه الامريكيه
واضاف ان الازمه في اوكرانيا بدات قبل
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه حسب تعبير
الدول الاوروبيه
الولايات المتحده انشئ التحالفن يضم الدول
الاوروبيه والاتحاد الاوروبي باستخدام
اوكرانيا
روسيا واشار في تصريحات صحفيه الى ان
الرئيس الروسي يعد لحرب طويله الامد
الاستنزافي اوروبا
واضاف ايضا ان الحرب في اوكرانيا يمكن
وقفها اليوم اذا قرر بوتين التخلي عن
السلاح ووصف الادمير الباور حرب روسيا ضد
اوكرانيا بانهاجيه وتفتقده الى اي مبرر
مشددا على ان الحلفه سيواصل دعم اوكرانيا
الرئيس الروسي لازم يفوت ان قال ان الهدف
من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في اوكرانيا
هو انهاء المعاناه والحرب المستمره منذ
سنوات في الضمه واضاف بوتين ان اوكرانيا
مارست الخداعه اكثر من مره وهي من دفعت
روسيا الى العمليه العسكريه ولم تترك
خيارا لها الا الحرب واشار بوتين الى ان
الازمه في اوكرانيا كان يمكن ان تنتهي
سلميه الا ان ما وصفه بغرور قادتها كان
كبيره
لم تتوقف العمليات القتاليه التي تشمل
الاسلحه الثقيله والمدفعيه والدبابات
والطائرات في دمباز منذ 2014 ما نقوم به
اليوم كجزء من العمليه العسكريه الخاصه هو
ومحاوله لوقف هذه الحرب وحمايه شعبنا الذي
يعيش في تلك المناطق لقد تحملنا لفتره
طويله وحاولنا التوصل الى اتفاق لكن تم
خداعنا وهذه ليست المره الاولى ومع ذلك
بدلنا قصار جهدنا لحل هذا الوضع بالوسائل
السلميه العدو كان يستعد لتحويل الصراع
برمته الى مرحله حاده وسخنه اكرر لم يكن
لدينا خيار سوى نفعل ما نقوم به الان
معي من موسكو استاذ العلوم السياسيه
الدكتور عمار قناه المزيد من المتابعه
دكتور عمار اهلا وسهلا بك ما الذي يستشف
من كلام الوزير خصوصا اتهامه هو علنا
للنيترو بانه هو من يشن الحرب على روسي
عبر اوكرانيا وان واشنطن اعدت لهذه الحرب
منذ فتره طويله
منذ سنوات يعني لا ننسى ان الازمه
الاوكرانيه هي لم تبدا يعني من الرابع
والعشرون من شهر شباط بل كانت لا يعني
ارهاقتها والاستعدادات ممكن القول منذ
بدايه يعني الثوره الملونه عام الثوره
البرتقاليه عام 2005 والث يعني ال ثوره
الميدان عام 2014 ومده تلك الفتره يعني
وبدات صراع الداخلي وممكن القول الحرب
الاهليه
في في اوكرانيا تم تعزيز يعني قوات الناتو
والتدريبات والزج العسكري لاوكرانيا وهذا
كله يعني ممكن القول يعني ضمن التواضع
يعني الاوروبي
الروماني والفرنسي وذلك
هي تصريحات يعني او ممكن اعتبارها ادانا
يعني عندما تحدث
من السؤال هل يهيء القادر رؤوس المسؤولون
الروس شعبهم لحرب طويله لا بل يعني اكثر
يعدونهم لتدحرج هذه الحرب كما يقول البعض
الى مستويات غير مسبوقه خصوصا على مستوى
مستوى نوعيه وفعاليه الاسلحه
السيد الكريمه فيما يتعلق في المجتمع
الروسي هو واعي يعني لما يجري الان ولما
كان يجري يعني في السابق هذه يعني
الترتبيه الاحداث هي ليست يعني جديده
للمواطن الروسي هو يعي تماما يعني الخطر
والتحديات التي يعني تواجهه الان يعني
تواجهه كامه وتواجهه ايضا يعني كدوله وفي
النهايه كان نظام سياسي فلذلك يعني
باعتقاد ان القراءه الخاطئه كانت يعني
مواد البدايه من الولايات المتحده
والمعسكر الغربي يعني من تداعيات ما نراه
اليوم يعني على الارض هو تفاقمات سلبيه
التي يعني اليوم ستلحق اضرار كبيره
بالمنظومه الغربيه فلذلك يعني نحن على
اعتاب اليوم يعني مرحله جديده او ممكن
القول يعني مرحله اخرى والتي يعني ممكن ان
تبتسم بالتصعيد العسكري والابتعاد يعني
النهائي عن الحل الدبلوماسي في المراحل
الحاليه وذلك يعني في عدم وجوده يعني
الرؤيه الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه لهذه يعني
الازمه وما بعد الازمه وهنا يعني التورط
الاوروبي هو واضح جدا واليوم اوروبا تضحي
يعني بمصالحها
القوم الجيو الاستراتيجيه الامريكيه من
خلال الازمه الاوكرانيه في نفس السياق
دكتور عمار ان تزداد وتيره التصريحات من
المسؤولين الروس تجاه الدول النيتو
الاوروبيه وانها تمد همم كيف بالاسلحه
وهمم انه اراضيها منطلق لهذه الحرب
الا يؤشر الى ان الروس ربما يفكرون في
مرحله ما بتوسيع اطار وجغرافيا هذه الحرب
لتطال يعني اكثر من اوكرانيا همم يعني
بتعرف كل الكلام الان يدور انه ممكن ان
تتسع رقعه هذه الحرب لتصل على الاقل الى
بولندا
الطرح وذلك ان لا ننسى يعني ان التصريحات
هي لم تزداد يعني هي كانت منذ البدايه
والصراع يعني كما هو واضح الان يعني بات
اكثر وضوحا بانه ليس يعني صراعا ما بين
موسكوير اللي هو منذ البدايه وقبل يعني
العمليه العسكريه وهو متعلق يعني
بالضمانات الامنيه التي طلبت فيها روسيا
من الناتو والرجاء المتحده همم حول يعني
عدم تجزئه مفهوم الامن في المنطقه
الاوروبيه وعدم دخول اوكرانيا يعني حلف
الناتو فمن هو يعني نبدا فيما يت يعني
بتوسيع رقعه يعني المعارك او الاصطدام
باعتقادها روسيا اولا هي غير معميه وحلفا
الناتو والم
عسكر يعني هو غير معني بهذه المساله لان
الحديث يعني يجري عن حرب عالميه ثالثه
الكل في غنى عنها لكن يعني ما سالت
الانخراط يعني الجزء هو موجود من قبل من
قبل حلف النات وغير المباشر لكن ما تحذر
منه روسيا مرارا وهو الانجراف يعني لهذا
الانخراط من خلال يعني الدعم العسكري
والذي معه تدريجيا يعني يزداد كما ونوعا
جاي من موسكو استاذ العلوم السياسيه
الدكتور عمار قناه شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور
عمار على هذه المشكله
كشفت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان الولايات
المتحده ارسلت ذخائر الطوارئ المخزنه في
اسرائيل الى اوكرانيا وقالت الصحيفه وفقا
لمسؤولين ان القذائف مدفعيه وغيرها من
الذائر نقلتها امريكا من اسرائيل الى
اوكرانيا وذلك خلال فتره حكومه
واضافت الصحيفه ان مسؤولين اسرائيليين
اعرب في البدايه عن مخاوفهم من ان ذلك قد
يضر بعلاقاتهم عروسيا لكنها مسؤولينا
امريكيين اكدوا ان البنتاجون لم يكن بحاجه
الى اذن من اسرائيل لنقل هذه المخزونات من
الذخيره
الى القدس في مزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم اليهم هناك مراسل العربيه
زياد حلب زياد اهلا وسهلا بك لنشره
الخامسه هل هنالك التاكيدات اسرائيليه لما
نشرته ان يوركت تايمز كيف يتفاعل هذا
الخبر والى اي ماده هذا محرج لتل ابيب
بدون انشاء كربما نبدا من حيث انتهيت
تماما اسرائيل مررت
لروسيا
ول- اا بوتين بانها بانها لا تغيير عمليه
في الموقف الاسرائيلي من الحرب على
اوكرانيا خشيه من ان يفهم ما حدث على انه
همم عمليه همم دور اسرائيلي ما عسكري في
الحرب على اوكرانيا والسبب بان هذه
المخازن هي صحيح تابعه
للولايات المتحده ولكن اسرائيل تستخدمها
في كل حرب التقريبا تفتح هذه المخازن
واسرائيل تستخدم الذخائر التي فيها ولهذا
كان هناك نوع من القلق الاسرائيلي من ان
يفهم الامر روسيه على انه ايضا موافقه
اسرائيليه على دعم عسكري
الاسرائيليون فسروا بان بالفعل البنتاجون
هو من يقرر لان هذه املاك امريكيه همم في
همم موجوده في اسرائيل لكن لم يكن مفاجئا
ايضا
للاسرائيليين وخاصه الان لحكومه نتنياهو
ليس مفاجئا هذا التوقيت بالذات من
التسريبات همم نتنياهه شخصيا يتهم اداره
بايدينتابا بانها تسرب ل- للصحافه
الامريكيه امور من شانها ان تحرج اسرائيل
مره تتعلق بايران والان بهدف ربما
توثير العلاقات مع همم بوتين لانه هناك
علاقه خاصه بين بوتين ونيتانياه كما هو
معروف زياد هل فعلا ما زالت تل ابيب توازن
في موقفها همم من همم من هذه الحرب ام لا
الراي العامل الاسرائيلي بشكل عام بات في
صف اوكرانيا ايا تكون التابعات من خلال
متابعتك سواء للاعلام اسرائيلي او للمواقع
التواصل في اسرائيل
بدون ان شك بان الاسرائيليين بشكل خاص هم
مع الاوكرانيين في هذه الحرب اكثر مما هو
مع الروس ولكن
ربما الاختلاف الان ااا بعوده نتنياهو هو
ان اسرائيل تحاول ان تخلق توازنا مقدسا
نوعا ما في العلاقه مع الكرملين فيما يخص
هذه الحرب لان اسرائيل تعتبر نفسها جاره
لروسيا في سوريا وتحتاج الى التنسيق الصيغ
مع الجيش الروسي بخصوص الغارات ضد التبوضع
الايراني ولهذا لا تغامر في المجاهره
بمواقفها في اوكرانيا نراها تمتنع تماما
عن توفير اي اسلحه للاقرار رغم ان كيف
تطالب اتباعا مثلا بالقبه الحديديه وما
الى ذلك الى ان اسرائيل ترفض هذا الامر
خشيه من اغضاب عمليا روسيا مع وصول
نتنياهو الى السلطه بهذه الحكومه اليمنيه
المتطرفه سمها مشيت هل يمكن توقع
تغير في السياسه الاسرائيليه تجاه هذه
الحرب ام لا يعني ستظل الامور في هذه
المنطقه الرماديه زياد
هناك ضروره للتوازن ستبقى نوعا ما في
المنطقه الرماديه لان الغرب والولايات
المتحده همم مع اوكرانيا وهذا بالنسبه
يكون مشكله كبيره ان يصطدم بكل هؤلاء
وبالتالي سيحاول ان يوازن كما قلنا بهدف
الابقاء على العلاقه الخاصه مع بوتين فيما
يتعلق بروسيا بمعنى عدم اغضاض الكرملين
وربما مواقف نوعا ما مساعدات انسانيه
ومساعدات غير حربيه لاوكرانيا ستستمر كي
يقول للغرب ايضا بانه في الخانه
نعم من القدس العربيه زياد حلبي دائما
شكرا جزيلا لك زياده على كل هذه المتابعه
نشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه يدعو من تونس الى
تكثيفه ترحيل المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى
بلدهم
اهلا بكم من جديد
ان الكتله السياسيه الرئيسيه في البرلمان
الاوروبيه تطالب بادراج الحرس الثوري على
قوائم الارهاب الاوروبيه واضاف مراسل
العربيه ان البرلمان الاوروبي سيصوت غدا
على قرار يدعم الشعب الايراني ضد قناع
النظام
مفاوض العدل الاوروبي يشدد من جهته على ان
اوروبا تدعم تشكيل اليه تحقيق دوليه في
انتهاكات حقوق الانسان في ايران مضيفا ان
النظام يستخدم عقوبه الاعدام لارهاب
المحتاجين الايرانيين كما اكد ان حدث
الاحتجاجات في ايران تراجعت بسبب
الاعتقالات الجماعيه وبطش النظام على حد
وصفه
المزيد من المتابعه اذهب الى بروكسل الان
ينضم اليه مراسل العربي الذي يتابع هذا
الموضوع نور اهلا وسهلا بك همم هل فعلا
همم ثمه مشروع عقوبات اوروبي واضح ضد
ايران الان ام لا من الحديث مجرد افكار
فقط
لا هناك مشروع طالب اولا اهلا بك هناك
مشروع تم التوافق حوله على مستوى
دبلوماسيين للدول الاعضاء 27 هذا المشروع
يعرض لمصادقه وزراء اا خارجيه الاتحاد يوم
الاثنين المقبلي وهنا في بروكس
هذه
الحقيقه مشروع الحزم الرابع من العقوبات
وحسب بعض المصادر المطلعه
تشمل هذه الحزمه 17 مسؤولا منهم كبار
المسؤولين في الحكومه مثل وزير الرياضه
عدد من ضباط الحرس الثوري وهذه الحزمه
تشمل ايضا 20 كيانا همم مثل هيئه الاذاعه
والتليفزيون مثل الهيئات الاتصال وايضا من
بينها بين هذه الكائنات ال 20 همم 12
كيانا تابعا للحرس الثوري الايراني هذا
على مستوى بروكسلوا على الصعيد الدبلوماسي
وفي الايام المقبله تبقى مساله الثوريه
الايرانيه طرح مثل ما تفضلت بالحاحا من
جانب الكتل السياسيه الرئيسيه في
البرلماني
ومفوظ العدل الذي كان ينوب جوزيف بالجلسه
قال من ان الخيارات كافه مطروح امام
المجلس
منها
الاجراءات العقابيه ذات الصله بالحرس
الثوري هو لم يقل سندرج جهاز الحرس الثوري
كجهاز بس بس نور انت واثق متابعتك يعني
عند عندما جيد عندما تتكلم مع المسؤوليه
الاوروبيه حتى وراء الكواليس هل فعلا يمكن
ان تتجرا اوروبا على وضع الحرس الثوري على
قوائم الارهاب ام لا اوروبا تحادر ولا
تريد استفزاز ايران اكثر كما يقال
يعني هناك رد يقول ان
المسؤولون في الحاله في جهاز الحارس
الفوري موجودون في قوائم الارهاب عده من
سوريا الى قوائم الارهاب الاوروبيه الى
قوائم الدعم اوكراني بالمسيرات الى ضباط
ومسؤولين في الحدث الثوري همم في قوائم
العقوبات ذات السيره الانتهاكات حقوق
الانسان وان هذه المساله تظل مطروحه بصفه
المنتظمه بمعنى الاتحاد الاوروبي لن يتوقف
عن همم عن اضافه اسماء وكيانات اخرى تبع
الحرس الثوري او لغيره من المؤسسات
القمعيه في ايران
لكن بالنسبه لي الذين يعني يتمسكون بيده
وجهه النظر يقولون بما انها تمكن في جميع
حالات ان تبقى على قناه الحوار المفتوحه
مع ايران مثل ما اكد همم
مفوض العدل الاوروبي من ان ايران من ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يحتاج الى قنوات التواصل
مع ايران سو بالنسبه لي ابلغي هذا الموقف
من الاحتجاجات وبالنسبه للرهائن المتزوجي
الجنسيه
في ايران او بالنسبه لي الاوضاع الاقليميه
والعلاقات معروف ولكن
جيد ولكن هل جرت بين المانيا وبعض الدول
الاوروبيه هل مساله سحب السفراء
الاوروبيين من طهران مطروحه على بساط
البحث ام لا هذا غير مطروح اطلاقا حتى ولو
للتشاور
يعني اذا همم فهمنا عباره الخيارات كافه
مطروح على طاوله طويله المجلس الوزاري
بمعنى ذلك ان منها الحرس الثوري الايراني
ربما ايضا قطع العلاقات او دعوه السفراء
للتشاوب ولكن لم اسمع اطلاقا بهاته بهذا
الاقتراح على اي مستوى وفي اي جلسه
باستثناء
المعارضه الايرانيه وبعض انصارهم من
الاوروبيين لان قتل العلاقات بمعنى ان همم
كافه سليم الحوار قد تنتهي والتواصل ينتهي
تماما مع ايران وما معنى ذلك ان العلاقات
تدخل في مرحله اخرى هذا من نحن من ناحيه
اخرى الاتحاد الاوروبي مثل الولايات
المتحده منشغل يعني تقريبا على مدار
الساعه بما يجري في اوكرانيا هل الاتحاد
الاوروبي في وجهي ان يفتح مواجهه اخرى في
المنطقه مع ايران ربما قد يحدث ذلك في
المستقبل ولكن ليس مطروح ساكتفي بهذا
القدر مين بروكسل المراسل العربيه نور
الدين لفريده شكرا
يزيلا لك نور على كل هذه المجموع
في شان ايرانيين متصل اعلن مصدر
دبلوماسيون فرنسي لوكاله فرانسبريس ان
المواطن الفرنسي الايرلندي برنار فيلر
المحتجز في ايران منذ اكتوبر الماضي في
حاله صحيه خارجه مشيرا الى ان المحتجزه
تظهر عليه مؤشرات الارهاب النفسي والجسدي
كما اكد ان السلطات الايرانيه ترفض حتى
الان الافراج عن فلان لاسباب صحيه رغم
مطالبه السلطات الفرنسيه والايرنديه بذلك
يزور المبعوث الامريكيه الخاص للشرق
الاوسط بغداد بالتزامني مع زياره قائد
القدس الايراني الجنرال اسماعيل
خطط لهما في وقت سابق بهدف في فتح حوار
مباشر بين دولتيهما بشكل غير عالميه
الزيارتان ستمهدان حسب المسؤول لوضع خطوط
عريضه لبدء جولات حوار جديده حول الملف
النووي في مقابل تخفيف الضغط على العراق
بقضيه التداول الدولار واستفاء ايران
ايرادات الغاز المصدر للعراق بالدولار
بدلا من الدماء
يشير المسؤول العراقي الى انه جرى الترتيب
اا لذلك في حوار بغداد الشهر الماضي
برعايه فرنسيه وفرنسا هي الساعه الى ان
يساعد العراق في دفع طهران للحوار بشان
الاوضاع في سوريا والازمه الاوكرانيه
باعتبارها حليفا قويا لروسيا وهي حليف
سياسي مطلع اشتراط هو الاخر عدم الكشف عن
اسمه اشار الى ان المبعوث الامريكي تحدث
عن مخاوف من تجدد قصف الفصائل للسفاره
الامريكيه والبعثات الدبلوماسيه الاخرى
وصلت نائبه الامين العام للامم المتحده
امين محمد الى كابو لمناقشه السياسات ودعم
وتعزيز حقوق النساء والفتيات واكد رئيس
الافغاني السابق حامد كرزايه انه التقى
بالمسؤول الامميه في كابول وقال ان موضوع
التعليم الفتيات والحوار الوطني تم
التاكيد عليه في هذا الاجتماع
الامين العام فرحان حق رفض اعطاء تفاصيل
عن برنامج الوفا مبرر ذلك بدوا عن امنيه
فيما تاتي الزياره بعد ان مدد الامين
العام للامم المتحده امام مجلس الامن
بالهجمات غير المسبوقه ضد النساء والفتيات
الافغانيه
الى كابول الان ينضم الي من هناك مراسل
العربيه عبد الله نادر عبد الله اهلا
وسهلا بك ما الذي تحمله السيده امينه محمد
الى كابول
خصوصا اجتماعاتها مع مسؤوليه حركه طالبان
وفق المعلومات المتوفره لديك
يبدو ان الاتصال غير متوفر الان مع عبد
الله لنا عوده اليه فورا جونسي
اعلن انا المبعوث الاماميه للسودان
افولكربيرز ان الامم المتحده تعمل في سياق
صراع سياسي حاد في السودان وذلك يعود الى
ازمه الثقه بين المدنيين والعسكريين
بالتزامني مع وجود اطراف ترفض العمليه
السياسيه ولا تريد نجاحها واكد بيرتس انه
رغم بطء سير العمليه السياسيه الا انها في
المسار الصحيح معبرا عن تفاؤله بالتزامن
او بالتزام الاطراف السياسيه بهذا الاتفاق
اكدت السفيره السعوديه لدى واشنطن الاميره
ريما بن بندر خلال مؤتمر دابوس ان العلاقه
بين الرياض واشنطن اساسيه لاستقرار العالم
وان الولايات المتحده شريك استراتيجي وان
علاقه البلدين طويله الامل
اصدقاء وهذه العلاقه تحاسمه وضروريه
امريكا وفي الشرق الاوسط المملكه العربيه
السعوديه من مصلحه العالم ان نحافظ على
قوت هذه العلاقه لاننا نكن لبعضنا البعض
المحبه وليس مجردا المصالح وربما من الصعب
احيانا ان يؤدي دور السفيره لدى واشنطن
لكنني اعمل بهذا المنصب بكل فخر ليس لانني
اول امراه لان ارث هذه العلاقه بني على
صعيدا شخص ويمتد لاعوام طويله
والولايات المتحده او اي دوله اخرى
استراتيجيان واصدقاء منذ اكثر من 80 عاما
ووقفنا جنبا الى جنب عند المواقف الهامه
بعض هذه اللحظات معروفه بعضها خاصه لكن
هذه العلاقه عمرها 80 عاما وستبقى ل 80
عاما اخرى لان هذا ليس فقط لمصلحه
الولايات المتحده لمصلحه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذه الشراكه تخلق علما اكثر
استقرارا نعكس ذلك في اوقات النزاعات
والجائحه وعندما حشدنا مجموعه العشرين
الى مقاطع من حواري مع مراسل العربيه في
كابول عبد الله نادر حول زياره هذا الوفد
الاموي عبد الله اهلا وسهلا بك ما الذي
تحمله السيده امينه محمد الى كابول وهل
طالبان فعليا منفتحه على اعاده العمل
بتعليم الفتيات وعودتهم سواء الى المدارس
والجامعات ام لا هذا الكلام غير صحيح
فقد وصلت امينه محمد النائبه الامين العام
للامم المتحده يرافقها في هذا في هذه
الزياره وفد رفيع المستوى من الامم
المتحده وجاء هذا الوفد لمناقشه الفرامل
الاخيره التي استهدفت النساءه وخاصه في
الحقل التعليمي وكذلك في حق العمل ااا
يبدو ان طالبان قد تتنازل من بعض مطالبها
او من بعض شروطها همم وبحسب مصادر من داخل
الطالبان فان طالبان ليس لها شروط او
مطالب كثيره في هذا الصدد فانها فقط تطالب
همم بالالتزام همم بالالتزام بالحجاب
الشرعي همم هذه الموظفات في همم اللواتي
اعمالنا في هذه المنظمات همم بحسب طالب
يجب ان يلتزمنا بالحجاب شرعي والاسلام وقد
تستني ان في كذلك بعض المنظمات الدوليه
والمحليه والمشاريعها
للمشاهدين في كل المنظمات الدوليه او لا
في منظمات بعينها مسموح للمراه الافغانيه
اا ان تعمل في الطالبان على ان تلتزم
بالزي الشرعي الذي تفرضه حكومه الطالبان
في منظمات بعينها ام لا ستسمح للنساء
الافغانيات في العمل في جميع المنظمات
الدوليه
نعم هناك منظمات قد ابدت استعدادها
لاستئناف مشاريعها وانشطتها الاغاثيه
والانسانيه همم في مقدمهتها انقذ الاطفال
فانها ابدت استعدادها همم شريطه ان تسمح
طالبان لموظفاتها للعمل هذه المنظمات
الاغاثيه التي علقت همم مشاريعها الاغاثيه
تحتاج اليها ساحه الافغانيه في هذه الايام
فان الشتاء القارس قد حل همم بالاراضي
الافغانيه وهناك مجموعات من الاطفال
والنساء والمراهقين كذلك يموتون في هذا
البرد القارئ القارس
ومساعدات ودعم هذه المنظمات يجب ان يصل
الى هذه الشريحه الضعيفه من النساء
والاطفال فقط
بان عمل ومشاريع هذه المؤسسات مهمه جدا
ولها حاجه ماسه في هذا في هذه الامنه بل
اعود الى السؤال المركزي بالنسبه الى عوده
الفتيات الى مقاعد الدراسه او ال ال ال
يعني البنات الافغانيات النساء الى حتى
الى الجامعه هل هنالك اتجاه اتجاهات
مختلفه حتى داخل حركه المانيا يعني سمت من
يريد همم ان تعود الامور مجراها الطبيعي
كما كانت في السابق ام لا يعني الكل متفق
على انه هذا ليس وقته وبالتالي هنا
المشكله
ب- بحسب المتابعه لقياده طالبان وكذلك
للشخصيات البارزه في في طالبان فان هناك
اختلاف في وجهات النظر همم محمد عباس
استانق زيد همم شخصيه البارزه تقول بان
بان
الفتاه تملك حق العمل وكذلك حق التعليمي
ويجب ان تفتح ابوابه المدارس والجامعات
امام الفتيات وهناك كذلك كثيرون مثل محمد
يعقوب مجاهد وزير الدفاع وكذلك وزير
الداخليه وهذا الوفد المكون من هذه
الشخصيات الكبيره همم قد ذهبت همم ذهب الى
ذهب لمناقشه همم هذه القضايا الشائكه بين
طالبان وبين المجتمع الدولي هناك بوادر ان
طالبان ربما تنسحب من همم من هذا من هذين
القرارين الاخرين همم القرار الذي يمنع
السيدات
الموظفات في المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه
كذلك من همم القرار الذي يمنع الفتيات من
مواصلات دراسه في الجامعات والمعاهد وقد
طل- قد قال طالبان بان همم يعني تضعوا همم
برامج ومنهج همم لهذه همم لهؤلاء الفتيات
في الجامعات وفي المعاهد وربما يرجعنا الى
همم الى دراسه عند اولادي اطلاله فصل
الربيع الذي سيبدا بعد شهرين
ساكتفي بهذا القدر عبد الله نادر موصل
العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الله على كل
هذه المعلومات
اعرب وزير الخارجيه الايطاليه انطونيو
تجاني عن قلق بلاد الجراه تفاقم تدفق
المهاجرين غير النظاميين الى ايطاليا
انطلاقا من السواحل التونسيه الوزير
الايطالي قال الاعلام التونسيه ان نحو 32
الف مهاجر غير نظامي وصلوا الى بلاده
العام الماضي بينهم 18 تونسيه
على ضروره تعزيز مراقبه الحدود البحريه
بين البلدين بشكل اكبر داعيا الى تكثيف في
عمليه الترحيل المهاجرين التونسيين غير
النظاميين الى بلدهم
نشهد الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
استنفار امني في عموم العراق تحسبا
لاحتفالات فوز المنتخب في نهائي خليجي 25
اهلا بكم جديد اعلن الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان عن امكانيه تحديد الرابع عشر من
مايقبل موعد الاجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بدلا من 18 من يناير
اردوغان اضافه ايضا خلال حديثه لنواب
العداله والتنميه في البرلمان ان الاتراك
سيظهرون رد فعلنا على المعارضه الرئيسيه
مثل ما حدث في انتخابات عام 1950
وقال الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ان
المجموعه التي وصفها بالداعمه للاستعمار
والمكونه من سته اشخاص في المعارضه ستعيد
تكرار تاريخ الانتخابات التركيه قبل 73
عاما كما ذكر
سنقول كفى لهؤلاء المقدرين والمتحمسين
للاستعمار هذه المجموعه التي لا تتمتع
بالكفاءه والمكونات من سته اشخاص يتحدوننا
مره اخرى في نفس اليوم بعد مرور ثلاثه
وسبعون عام
ذكر الرئيس الجديد لحزب الحاكم في تايوان
لايت انه لا داعي لاعلان استقلال البلاد
عن الصين الى ان تايوان والصين لا يتبعني
باي شكل من الاشكال بعضهما
تايوان دوله مستقله وذات سياده ولا داعي
لاعلان استقلال تايوان بشكل منفصل تايوان
لبعضهم البعض كما يمكن للشعب التايواني
23 مليون شخص ان يقرر مستقبله بنفسه
ازاله حالات الوفيات ولا اصابات بجرثومه
الكوليرا الشماليه غير سوريا تحديدا في
مخيمات النازحين وذلك نظرا للاوضاع
الخدميه السيئه وعدم توافر الرعايه الطبيه
الكافيه
ات النازحين السوريين لتتزمن الماساه
الانسانيه مع ازمه صحيه المنظمات المحليه
والدوليه في شمال غربي سوريا حذرت من
ارتفاع في اعداد الاصابه بالكوليرا بشكل
غير مسبوقه بين النازحين في المخيمات
العشوائيه
تضم عشرات المخيمات فيها اكثر من نصف
مليون ناجح اصبحوا الان معرضين لخطر
الكوليرا لتكون الظروف الخدميه لديهم
عاملا مساعدا لانتشار الجرثومه
النازحون يعيشون حاله من الخوف والقلق
البالغين بعد تسجيل ست وفيات بمرض
الكوليرا والاشتباه باكثر من 50 حاله
مصابه بالمرض ذاته قبل ايام
الاعداد التراكميه للفتره الماضيه في شمال
غرب سوريا وصلت الى 20 حاله وفاه
والاصابات سجلت
37,500 منها 6000 خلال الشهر الحالي وافقي
مديريه صحه ادلب مع استمرار تفشي المرض
تبقى الارقام عرضه للزياده ويبقى الاطفال
الاكثر ضرارا
المديريه ذاتها اكدت ان دفعه من اللقاحات
ستدخل المنطقه تم تقديمها من قبل اليونيسف
وتحالف العالمي للقاحات الى عمر العربيه
افاده مصدر عراقي برفع الانذار الامني الى
مستوى جي في عموم العراق ابتداء من يوم غد
عند السادسه صباحا الى غايه السادسه من
صباح الخميس اي الى حين انتهاء الاحتفالات
في حال فوز المنتخب العراقي وكان وزير
الداخليه العراقي قد وجه بالاستغفار
الكامل لجميع القطاعات الامنيه داخل المدن
في جميع المحافظات ومنع اطلاق الاعيره
الناريه والقبض على المخالفين ضمن
استعدادات نهائي خليجي 25 كما اكد على
ضروره الاحتفال بطريقه حضاريه تليق
بالعراق في حال فوز المنتخب الوطني في
نهائي بطوله الخليج العربي بنسختها ال 25
امام نظيره العماني
نشره الخامسه انتهت اطيب التحيات والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]